so welcome uh folks to our new
councilors and those returning
to what will hopefully be a different
way of doing business
just want to start off by reminding Tom
and Grant that that sort of laughter
before the meeting's not an appropriate
way to go forward he says jokingly
um look we've got quite a bit of an
agenda to get through today
um
first thing we're going to do is do the
swearing in process for Angie and for
Leslie so we'll do that shortly and then
we've got quite a long level of work to
get through particularly around the
standing orders and the codes of
conducts and the likes so Michael's
going to sit at the top of the table for
about four or five hours as we do that
it's my intention that we go through
Page by page it doesn't mean that we
need to read every page just needs to be
give an opportunity for anybody that
might want to contribute to something
they see that's new
because there are quite a bit of changes
coming in into the standing walls and
into the code of conduct process as well
and the subsequent paper at the end of
the uh the end of the meeting deals with
the money funeral rolls so um
we just work our way through that so I
guess uh we've got two apologies at the
stage which is Alex and Ria are both
away moved
thank you thank you
in the opposition to that
all right
yes I'll put their motion all those in
favor thank you
swearing and now
do you usually there's a bit of this
place for that
why is he
yeah
I declare that I will faithfully and
impartially and according to the best of
my skill and judgment execute and
perform in the best interest of the
invercargill city the powers authorities
and duties vested in or imposed upon me
as an elected member of the invercargill
city council by virtue of the Local
Government Act 2002 the local government
official information and meeting act
1987 or any other Act
so help me God
it is
foreign
judgment execute and perform the best
interests of the invercargill city
council
the powers authorities duties visited
them or post on me as an elected member
of the invercargill city council by
virtue of the Local Government Act
2002 the local government official
information and meetings act 1987 for
any other Act
s
thank you
so are there any uh Declarations of
interest that we need to be aware of
people we don't already know about
being them
oh so um we just need to move and have a
signal that we receive the Declaration
of the Mayan councilors we're going to
move the three uh motions yep thank you
second left yep thank you all those in
favor
thank you
okay and the mayor's report to the
inaugural Council
that's recommended that we um
receive that report
and they have some other recommendations
that go with it
it's not going to have somebody move
that initially I guess on the first
point that we received the report
I'll move that thank you
second
are all those in favor
thank you very much
so this report now okay is goes through
some of the appointments have been made
under my delegated authority
and so it's important that we work our
way through there to make sure that
everybody's comfortable with the
appointments and with the membership of
the councils
so I guess we've read those so any point
to be raised
which is the appointment to the
appointments uh there's a spelling
mistake in their infrastructure but
they're using the answer for the bottom
I think it should be counted a scale
just got scared
this one
don't mind that I'm sure you don't so
Peter you you declare an interest on
that on that committee sorry did you
declare them just on that committee no
sir spelling
it's not on that um
it's on board books okay yeah
thank you
so there being no further discussion on
your worship yeah me all do thank you
thank you
um your worship I'm just interested in
the
finance and projects committee
which is obviously a very busy committee
with very wide-ranging responsibilities
yes and the fact that it's only
um
listed here with six members whereas the
others have eight nine and ten sure yeah
I can explain that
um
and I accept that you went here when we
had the initial discussion about it
um it was very much my wish that for the
two peripheral committees which are
finance and projects and risk and
assurance that we had people on those
committees that had a desire to be there
they're quite unique areas to work in
and so uh I didn't necessarily want to
get eight or nine or ten people on there
only to find it I had people here that
weren't interested in that sort of work
the two main committees clear is where
the bulk of the work will be in Council
so at this stage we've got six plus
myself
because I you know I'll be on that
committee as well so unless I get people
to put the hand up and say yes I'd like
to be involved I don't want to force
that issue
um you can see the numbers in here I
don't want people just making up numbers
I do apologize Mick like I thought I had
indicated I would be interested to be on
that committee oh well that's easily
added then
so I I think I had you on the arrest and
Assurance as well yes yes
excellent thank you
any other issues with the uh
the appointment sort of been made there
or any further discussion
okay looking for a motion Mick like I'm
happy to move two three four and five
with the addition of councilor Soper
into the finance and projects committee
yep excellent thank you for that a
second there yes thank you any further
discussion about that
you're being Nana put the motion all
those in favor
aye
any detention
not a vote against uh mayor Clark just a
question uh over what time period do you
want to go and fill those other
positions the council appointees to
other organizations yes
um we would held off on that because
council's way and Council of crackers
away and councilor bonds away and very
much wanted to not appoint people where
they weren't feeling comfortable and to
make sure that we had a fair sharing of
the workload or of the interest so I've
delayed it off I think when I was
talking to Claire we were talking about
um middle November yeah they're a couple
of weeks away just want to make sure
everybody's back and everybody gets a uh
saying what they'd like to do thank you
thank you very much for that
clarification
all right moving on to uh the adoption
of standing orders
awesome all right my error you might not
want that item
you can't get extra responsibilities
so we've got a report there that refers
to the staff responsibilities of members
um and it just requires that the council
will receive this report
would like to move that happy to move
that thank you counselor
signal
thank you
any discussion around the report we've
got Michael here to give his words of
wisdom
no um thank you mayor Clark this is
simply a summary of what has been
presented to the councilors at the
induction program and with the edition
of Mr Donnelly's report that he
presented uh
last week
um so no unless are there any specific
questions around these responsibilities
I'm very happy to leave it at that
foreign
like to move the adoption of that report
I'll move to you thank you
see you can then thank you all those in
favor
aye Carrie
now on to the larger report which I'm
trying to get to twice now but um which
is the option of standing orders
um this is quite a long report
and so I'd like to move through it in an
ordinary way and as we work through the
pages it would be helpful of people
indicate if they've got issues that they
want to do
um I've got as you can imagine a whole
lot so bear with me as I try to work
through what I've got to raise and also
work my way through but the
recommendations are that we were that we
received the report
and that we resolve to either include or
exclude from standing orders the ability
for the chairperson of a meeting to have
the casting vote so we agree with that
or we don't agree with that
and then it adopts standing orders for
the period of 2022 through to 2025 and
there's an appendix attached to that
so if you're on board books and you
start
up on page 19. we'll just work our way
through those
so if we go to page 20 and just
for members to let me know if there's
anything in page 20 that there I was
going to see and I'll just work my way
through
page 21
excuse me
sorry yeah um Mr Mia and now the the
casting voter we talk about that now
look
um it's my understanding that the
casting vote thing that if you didn't
have it and it was a tie
and the committee
um then the status quo would would
Prevail if it was a change but if you
come my question is if it was a vote
like we had in the last Council where
you're deciding on either option two for
the museum or option three and it's
something new
um and you're a stalemate then with even
numbers what what would be the way or if
that would be sorted yep I'll get
Michael to give us some advice on that
because if we don't have the casting
boat what would happen if we had a split
bite essentially the motion to pass
needs a majority if there's no majority
in the event of a tie the motion is lost
lost on a tie lost on the tie so it has
to be a majority if there's no casting
vote then that is lost on a tie because
it is even therefore the motion is
deemed to be lost
um and the event this counselor
pottinger was speaking of
where there was a course of two actions
that the emotion would either be lost or
it could be moved into and further
discussion could be taken place at a
later meeting with further information
provided by staff if that was required
so there's some options but
um just quick prices this was something
that lgnz has suggested that we talk
about at each meeting at the adoption of
standing orders as something that each
Council needs to make a call on it's
something that is considered a legacy to
give the chair casting vote uh it's not
considered
part of a modern Council
but a number of accounts will still find
it very useful to have in the event of
those tiebreakers so put prices on that
point
yeah I think in some some organizations
or when they've got a split bite without
a majority they sometimes go back to
have another bite of The Chariot alone
stage to sort of try and Lobby
colleagues to shift their positions and
I'm not sure that's a healthy process
for us
um but then there are always arguments
against the uh the casting boat of the
chair as well that can be contentious as
well so
I'll just leave that and we'll work our
way through running and we can come back
that when we come to the vote yeah
having some further discussion on down
there so working our way forwards
through just stop me at any stage and
want to clarify a link on page 20.
um page 21 uh you'll notice in later on
in the standing orders there are
Provisions around speaking to Rio at
meetings and so the chair has some
discretionary rights around that uh
notice has to be given to do that it
can't just be automatically done and the
chair can also ask for some translation
as well or we could have an interpreter
so the options there
um the signaling that there are
Provisions further on with us around
there
so moving on to Pages 23 and Beyond we
start into the the meet I guess of the
of the report they're coming forward
onto page
27 is the
weather in the prevention start the
profile as you go through
foreign
working my way through those those
definitions to start with I think a lot
of the stuff is well known to me but
so one page um
page 36 of board books you'll see this
is where the issues around
um and the ability to speak English to
Rea or sign language kicks in
um and the notice period and also that
the chair has some abilities to
to manage that that speaking in three
years well
as you're scrolling forward which I know
you're all doing just alert me if we
come to anything that you might want to
raise a lot of the stuff is just
standard that we've had before
I'm hearing nothing I'm up to about 50
now 52.
foreign
page 53
um
we have some issues around members right
to attend meetings
draw your attention to that
so on the top of 53 it talks about
apologies
and it says all apologies must be
provided to the chair chief executive or
governments and legal team prior to a
meeting we've had some discussion
already about that in their early stages
and it was a suggestion that um are
people that wish to make an apology
should do so to the mayor or in the
absence of being able to contact them
here to the deputy me and it's been my
observation last time and it makes it
really hard for cheers who are trying to
set up a meeting
and get things organized here to get a
last-minute telephone call that comes
through a third party about
um why they're an apology and we talked
we had this discussion a couple of weeks
ago about our desire to keep the
apologies low if we can and encourage
people to attend meetings so I just
wonder what you think about that that
second sentence which is all apologies
must come through one of three options
hoping for discussion on that especially
from the chairs themselves
I'll pick on you Darren yeah uh thanks
Mick Clark I guess just to reinfor
reaffirm that it is really useful as
soon as possible to let the chair know
if you're going to be an apology because
there have been times that we've had to
scratch around to make sure that we've
had a quorum yeah so um the last minute
ones look if something happens at the
last minute that's fine
um but the earlier we get them the
easier it makes it for us to prepare for
a meeting so you're still happy for it
to be in the chair
I think chair for the the meeting so if
it was listed as the mayor you might be
away yeah um so whoever is is running
the meeting should be the person that we
can go to so for full Council of a CPU
so given your long standing in this role
um how easy is it to decline an attempt
to have an apology if you think it's not
appropriate
it's the only time we've declined
apologies is
um when they've not come from the person
themselves okay
um somebody else has noted that
someone's missing yeah and lodged an
apology on their behalf that's not
really an apology I haven't
really struck anything where we've
declined an apology sure okay thank you
rangi look I totally agree with that
part but what I'd like to bring to the
attention is
um as chair when you're sitting up there
and it's three minutes to three
and you know you're looking around the
table and there are elected members
missing and you're not and you haven't
heard an apology I find that quite
frustrating
and then all of a sudden at one minute
three people walk in
um I I don't think that's acceptable
because you know I'm already I'm writing
my run sheet out and I'm I've got the
names written down as apologies
so I I think as courtesy and this is up
to yourself then I I think for meetings
that elected members be here you know 10
minutes before so you know you've got an
idea of what's happening I think it's
not out of the you know it's not gonna
it's not going to really muck up
someone's day to be here 10 minutes
before the meeting
you know so that I just like to make
that quite clear because it is quite
confusing Darren I don't know if you
strike that if you
it's a courtesy think I guess it makes
it easier for each elected
representative as well to be settled in
and ready for the meeting yeah so yeah
Trish and I were having a conversation
just part of us going well how early is
too early
poor old Pony has been here all day but
that's
here
um since standing orders allow for
apologies to be offered at the meeting
and particularly for lateness or for
having you leave early I think really
that means that the chair has to be able
to committee really has to be able to
accept apology
just from a practical
Alan were you wanting to contribute to
that
thanks Mr Mia oh I don't disagree I'll
just point out that the uh
um some cases such as my own potential
appearance at a court proceeding which
can mean that there is no
um possibility other than walking in
with only a couple of minutes to spear
um in I think people do understand that
it does happen on occasion I I certainly
in my position legally try to make sure
that it doesn't but there are always
cases when Court processes run over time
okay well I think in that case if you
are going to be
you know running to the wire that it
would be handy to know and then I I'm
not assuming that it's an apology yep
otherwise you're still in you're still
guessing sort of like half an apology
for maintenance
that can be difficult of course because
you have no idea until the court seating
is underway you whether it will run over
the specified time so I'm just pointing
out there could be a difficulty there
just one particular cases and it's not
only
how we operate
it's very difficult
oh well if there's no just
I guess a lot of us here have other jobs
besides being counselors and if I knew
that whatever I was doing had the
potential of interfering with me
arriving at three o'clock I'd forewarn
the chair just as a possibility uh
rather than have to do it during you
know you know that period of time I
think it's one of those things that if
we knew you were in court that would be
great with that's that's and we know we
know you're in town and uh you're only a
block away but how how would the chair
know otherwise
and I'm just I'm just raising that we
all have you know
um other other work
and I think if I was going to be running
late I'd be I'd be letting the tuna well
in advance just in case it happened
so I guess it's just something we try
and manage as we go through it causes
some itch at the moment
so you've got that Michael that we just
leave that as a status quo yes thank you
going forward now as I'm rolling through
the pages stop me where you need to stop
me
um I'll get on quickly onto page 55
because I'll get in the head of Leslie
and say there's actually a spelling
mistake there so I have one or sentence
right down near the bottom it says ID
the deputy chair and it should say if
the deputy chair
just a spelling there one of the things
we've got in this this section 14-2 it
refers to the chair or Deputy chair and
we don't actually have any Deputy chairs
anymore
so Our intention early on was that where
a chair couldn't make a meeting that the
deputy mayor would take over the
chairmanship all of that role
so
um
and that's just something for you to be
aware of Michael
foreign
during this document there's quite a bit
of um and this is something historical
that you might be help help us with down
at quite a few places it says we're the
chairperson stands the person that's
speaking who the standing needs to sit
down we don't operate that way anymore
um we haven't had to
no but if you wanted to stop a debate
which I thought was getting out of
control or give some guidance to where
this where it's going would you
physically stand up to do that or would
you
um speak a bit louder or what would you
do I I think it's a matter of degrees
yep
um and and that you would measure how
much attention you had of whoever it was
that you were wanting to pause and if
they weren't then you accelerate your
volume yeah and if that doesn't work
there's a gavel which you can either
bang or toss yeah
of course or the the last option is to
rise but actually it's been so long
since I've seen anybody do that I'm not
sure that people would have recognized
that when the chair Rises all businesses
yeah especially if I stood up and no one
would know the difference I wasn't going
to say anything you're my home
okay just on that Mr Mia the uh gavel
was no longer there we had to remove it
in the additional screens for Zoom were
added unfortunately
yeah you could put it here somewhere I'm
sure
but okay no that's fine
um it's a cider
so it might be Michael that there are
several places where that's recorded
about the standing but we might just
want to tweak that a little bit just so
because it refers to that you should be
seated and then not speak when the chair
is doing it just the not speak would be
the way for what I would think and
thinking black very happy to adjust that
to the modern era
yeah and there's quite a few quite a few
places that occurs
um so unless there's any objection we'll
move on to up to page 65 and we come to
the contentious issue of electronic
devices at meetings
um
excuse me but before you get to 65 over
the question on page 64. yeah
um so 21.5
um the last phrase there says maybe
subject to standing order 20.6 I think
it's meant to be 21 but dot six
okay yes yep thank you thank you
let's start moving on again to 20.11
21.11 which is electronic devices
um we've had a considerable amount of
discussion in the last term around the
use of electronic devices in the chamber
um we've had people that are off the
away on some other business and you'll
be aware of that we've had potentially
people being contacting members by way
of technology and they could be
influencing the Democratic prices
um but then we have people who have
children as well who need to keep their
phones open so
um my view on that and I'm open to
having some discussion about that is the
status quo should remain but that we
have an eye cast across us that if it
gets out of line we will just tighten up
the provisions around around the
technology because it can interfere and
it doesn't look good if people are seen
to be prompting other people during the
debate
so um I've seen some nodding around town
over there if anybody's not comfortable
with them now is the time to say
I'd agree with that may clack I think
there have been times where you know I'm
running a business so occasionally I've
had a fire off a quick message but we
have been notified by members of the
public um Express and concern about the
amount of time that some people are
spending on devices that's no longer an
issue
um for that person but it's just
something that we need to be aware of
yeah the opening paragraph on this is
the key that it's okay to be used for
the advancement of the business
so I mean I've sat on this chamber and
we've been discussing things in five
seconds later rangi pipes up and he's
he's got online somewhere and pulled out
some legislation for us and that's quite
helpful at times to have that sort of
people that are fast on technology and
Alex is another one that can do that as
well to draw that forward it helps the
business run but once it goes into other
parameters it's not so good so yep I
think so so Mr Mia Peter I find it very
hard to hear what you're saying at times
yep now just getting back to uh cell
phone I didn't hear what you're not
allowed to have these here any longer no
no the um what a scissor net provision
is that you can use a cell phone in the
chamber for advancing the business so if
you were wanting to jump into some piece
of legislation and draw it on yourself
and it's fine
um we don't mind
urgent business I know you've got a wife
it's very unwell Alex has got a child
that she sometimes needs to keep in
contact that's okay too but we don't
want people prompting themselves across
the table to talk to other people by way
of cell phone during a debate
um it doesn't look good or to be online
safer I'm saying watching the uh
um the Melbourne cup the Melbourne cup
yes I just thought that was rather
appropriate you you mentioned that for
Peter about five o'clock yeah five
o'clock could still be here
um so at this stage we're just going to
leave it the way it is Peter Standard
Supply yep thank you very much but it
gets Beyond uh it's something we need to
monitor yep thank you very much
okay it's worth pointing out mayor Clark
that uh for the new councilors that if
you've got a phone and you put it on
vibrate please don't leave it lying on
the table because it vibrates on the
table go straight up the mic stands and
those who are zooming and it's all they
can hear
stick it in your pocket it's kind of
comforting
so that's all I've been going forward
onto page 66 for me
um and 22 6 there are a couple things
here I'm I'm personally not comfortable
about
um it's around the provision and some of
them have been here some of the other
members have been here for a while will
know about this provision which um sort
of determines that if three people have
spoken consecutively in support of
something
then you can call for a motion to
um
to uh close the discussion down I guess
one or a bit of words but it does allow
the chair to open up the opposition
stuff as well
um one thing I'm uncomfortable about
that is and we've had this exercise
before there's there are two things for
me you don't want discussions to go on
forever and a day but there are times
when we want to hear from every voice at
the table
um it's important on some of these like
three Waters a good example around the
mandate
passport mandates that we had all right
it was important from a democratic
Pacifica to hear every voice and so I
think somehow that needs to be worded
um
that allows for that and when I looked
at Michael where it says the chairperson
must put the motion
um just changing that to the word may
put the motion gives the chair some
discretion again so I'd be interested to
know what other members have to think
about that
um I found that a little bit
uncomfortable at times
yeah
um look I'd agree with that
interpretation I think there are times
when it has been useful that if
we've got people speaking all in the
same direction for the sake of almost
hearing their own voices that hasn't
helped but on those contentious issues
doing a round table you just drop that
count and yeah continue around sure
yeah sure um is
it no you're right um
like a lot of the business we do doesn't
require lots of voices a lot of it can
be quite mundane stuff but there are
some stuff with it where the committee
wants to hear what we individually have
to think on the on the issue
at least me
thanks Mr Mia I suppose the only slight
caveat I put on to changing that
particular must to May is that it says
the chairperson must put the motion
after the move as right of reply yep
normally the right of reply
would trigger the motion to be put
because it's the last speaker yeah
um so it may be
that there needs to be some
extra sentence if there's no speaker of
the country the chairperson
um will repeat the call before asking
the Mover to give their right of reply
sure there may be some way to word to
account for the fact that the move is
right of reply is usually the last
the last speech full stop
so my understanding here Michael is that
after you've had three speakers
regardless of whether there's any to the
country or not the Mover has the right
to reply even to those that are in the
infirmative who are agreeing with that's
why I understand it yes but it's just
what stage do we trigger and is there
any discretion because at this stage
there doesn't seem to be
and I think it would be helpful if that
was left to a chair to decide
so at this stage that that provision
doesn't provide for a discretion once
that happens then that is what happens
the only way around it would be to seek
to suspend standing orders which also
leads to its own problems as you're then
trying to manage the rest of the meeting
sure
so yes there would be a way to word it
yeah
sorry Nigel were you wanting some input
there
did you want some input into that did
you have yeah no just have a scratch
yeah Tom
um she doesn't understand the issue is
that you're concerned at the moment
implies that only three speakers can
speak
um I think the second sentence actually
deals with a certain difficult different
point but rather than three you just
need to put several and leave it to the
chair to say that that point yeah well
the way I understand it and others have
been here much longer than me can
clarify this the three speakers are are
in support of one position so they're
either affirmative or the opposed
there's the option for then another
three to come in on the other side of
the debate so it's six we've got 13
elected members here that means half
your people are not getting a say and so
um you know I just wanted us to consider
that option because it can be used as a
tool to close down some debates at times
yeah down so I guess by way of
explanation from how things have been
able to happen anytime somebody changes
the direction of the argument there's a
reset
so you could have three four one against
then you can go back to another three
four but actually the way it's worded
here is is sufficient because it says
online to the chairperson may call for a
speaker to the contrary
or they may not it might be one of those
examples where we want to go around the
table
in which case the wording as it is is
sufficient
so I guess it's a matter of
how we interpret that
Michael do you want to give some some
thoughts on that
I think
away with all pieces of legislation or
quasi legislation there are lots of ways
you can interpret it
um
in this case it councilor laddle is
right you do have that reset
um but the the wording there is that the
chair position must a business speaker
to the country so
carry on with that pattern but it
doesn't necessarily mean that every
elected voice is going to be heard
if there are
three people against and the rest of the
elected members are going to be four
unless you manage to space that out I
think there is some wording that we can
put in there to help achieve the aim of
enabling all counselors to have a
discussion but giving the chair the
ability to control their meeting and if
a motion is put on this point saying
they've been sufficient just needs to
end there are other ways around that
sort of like a closure motion for
example is the appropriate way to end a
debate that is
going around the table so question of
clarification if I may clack it says
that the chair may call for a speaker to
the country but what if the chair
doesn't
and so the chair as the as you'll know
councilor Ludlow is a very experienced
chair uh the chair has the authority to
determine how that meeting is to be run
if the chair decides not to then the
chair's all in his final so that current
wording works then
if the chair's intention is to not call
for any further discussion than yes
but if the chair's intention is to
enable everybody to discuss and there
are procedural points being
raised understanding orders that makes
it difficult for the chair to control
those other than having to deal with
each procedural Point including things
like closure motions thank you um and I
guess if I use the vaccination passport
May clack as an example
um I chaired that meeting I did point
out at the beginning of the process that
I would be going around the table and
expecting all counselors so there you've
clearly stated an intention to not
follow a 343 against process
or alternatively say that I plan on
following standing orders which is the
yeah three four having said that I've
also been subject to
um a group Mark who might be um
um speaking to a certain position
and then we've had other members that
say well you've gone past your three
quota now I suggest that we have some
sort of closure to it and this is people
warning speaking often and that's what I
want to avoid not using that too often
because I think it's important that we
don't have the same voices all the time
it's important we have robust debates
where they need it so I'm open to where
we think Leslie
thanks Mr Mia I was just wondering if
um to try and move things forward
because that does say the cheer person
may call for a speaker to the country
and what we're trying to do is elicit
all opinions of those who have not yet
spoken would it be a simple addition to
say this chairperson may call for a
speaker to the country or ask for an
opinion from those who have not yet
spoken
would that clarify what you're trying to
achieve yeah when I look at the if you
look at the speech uh the the flowchart
that's on page 84 of board books it's
got um
it clarifies how we deal with that and
as it comes down it says motions
discussed if three consecutive speakers
in support or opposition the chairperson
may call for a speaker to the country so
if he does he or she does that and there
are none and then it says and if there
are none
um the motion shall be put to the um
shall be put to the boat out to the
right of reply yep that's the right
reply which is the initial data and I
would have thought there if we use the
word May and instead of shell it gives
that discretion
to say okay we've heard three in favor
anybody opposed no there's no there's
anybody still in favor that would like
to speak but that doesn't help that
provision doesn't quite help there
yep uh rangi come look previous previous
terms I've been on uh especially the
early ones
the use of suspending they you know
suspension of standing orders was often
used when it was a something like that
vaccination passport thing that that was
used a couple of times but Michael
raises an interesting point if you
suspend standing orders then you're
throwing all your rules out including
if it was a cast if that depending on
what we choose on the casting bag
standing orders
so the correct way of going through that
is to name the standing order that you
play suspending so that that's right you
would actually suspend uh the voting one
and that can easily be done which is
they just need to remember which one it
is yeah yeah so I think I think the
chairperson's ability to do that yes
it's been that particular order how
would that work Michael
uh can be a request from any member but
doesn't it have to be done at the start
of a meeting if you're going to suspend
standing orders
can we I've seen it done just for that
particular discussion yeah yeah it's
it's a something that can be done before
each item uh if required and uh the
governance team are always here so we'll
be able to point out to you there's a
specific standing order if you let us
know what you're seeking to achieve
time
I'm picking up the consensus right and
we just leave it the way it is but the
chairs be aware of their ability to
suspend standing water on particular
items if they want to to allow for
further debate if that becomes an issue
with those that don't want the further
to make yep
okay
it's all good good luck with remembering
what standing order you need to suspend
so this report goes on right up to um
sorry before you leave page 66 cheer to
five yeah me sure um 22.5 The Heading is
members may speak only once actually the
two sentences that follow that the first
one says you cannot speak without the
permission of the chairperson and the
second sentence says you may speak with
the permission of this the chairperson
um both both scientists they actually
see exactly the same thing in both
settings you say that you can speak more
than once with achievements permission
so I'm I'm not really clear what the
actually to be honest I'm not clear
about the purpose of it is at all
because the effect that the heading
should be members may speak more than
once with achievement's permission
Michael
thank you Mr Mayor so the
the purpose of that is that members can
only speak once that is the wall
however as we've discussed already today
the chairperson has the discretion to
enable all sorts of things understanding
orders and that includes allowing
members to speak again uh so the
starting point is always
essentially is just discuss you get one
bite at the Cherry so that's your chance
to say everything you want to say it's
to stop people constantly going back and
back to our end our end
um let's get it out say what you need to
say and then
if you've got a valid reason for needing
to add something the chairperson can
grant you that dispensation but it's
a benefit from a gift from the chair as
opposed to a right
but I also agree the sequencing things
are Superfluous so we will probably
delete that
like it's been my experience that the
cheers that I've come in contact with in
the last term have allowed people to
bounce back a little bit sometimes you
hear a little bit more information and
it makes you question again but it can
be messy if the chairs don't control it
for sure
I don't have any other issues on the uh
on the standing orders but if others do
now is the time to race as we go forward
so it's possibly useful mere Clark for
me just to remind everybody about the
Quorum rules and with zoom there's Zoom
now no longer accounts for Quorum so you
need to be in this room and that was
only a temporary measure under the
covert legislation and that has now
lapsed so it would be helpful to remind
everybody of that
excellent no further debate but somebody
like to move the three motions we've got
the end to give us an indication on on
option two of which they'd like to have
the include or exclude the casting way
to the chair
you're Barry you would so what would you
what would you in and what would you
prefer on the included exclude
do you want the chair to have that
casting Vote or not in the motion you're
putting forward I think you should do
should do okay so um something like the
second there well second there thank you
so it might be helpful just to do these
three independently or somebody suggest
that we we do two separately so if you
want to have a bait on there there's any
distinction to that
thank you Leslie
looking for a segment
yep thank you so we if we do just one
and three together at this stage so we
can come back to two
um all those in favor
any opposition
excellent thank you for that and on on
the issue two that we've also got on the
table uh is there so the motion is to
include the casting vote with the chair
which is what we do at the moment
so I'll put that to the vote as well oh
sorry Leslie um
absolutely yes you're welcome to speak
on it thank you
um I'm not weathered to either position
but I'm just conscious that we are
trying
um in this term to be a very collegial
Council and I do just want to bring up
so that everybody has thought about the
fact that if we are in a position where
a casting vote would traditionally be
new be be used under as
um Eric Weiser has pointed out very old
sending order rules that it may be that
this Council would feel it was more
productive to allow some more time for
that decision to be
reinvestigated more information should
be collected and that that may be a more
productive collegial approach than a
casting vote to be used so I just want
people to have considered that
particular aspect of moving into a new
era with a new Council yep so I
appreciate that and certainly from my
perspective and I hope the cheers would
go down this track as well that where we
have very contentious decision making
and we've had some of that in the past
where the chairs casting votes really
split the council down the middle that
we would not necessarily um go down the
path of using a casting boat that we
could just um adjourn it to give
ourselves more time to think about the
versions I think that would be a healthy
process now whether you want to write
that in somewhere or whether it would
just be an understanding that chairs
could use themselves I think that would
be a good thing to do
so uh having heard that um the
resolution is to include the casting
plate option for the chairperson
um all those in favor
any any opposition
yep excuse me you want that recorded
thank you on that particular matter yes
okay that's fine thank you that's caring
all right now we move on to the um
adoption of the code of conduct
being with me as I get to that
so we have um three sets of
recommendations here that we receive the
report
which is a code of conduct 2022 that we
revoke the equivalent in 2016. and we'd
adopt the code AS set out in appendix a
so again I'll just work my way through
that and people are welcome at this date
before we put the motion to to bring up
some issues I'm sorry stop me if I get
too far ahead on page 93 of boardwalks
and 94. I've got some opposition myself
to the provision under the new code
that's been proposed to allow a member
of the public to Lodge a code of conduct
so I think back into the last term I
think around
the vaccine mandation and around uh the
Groundswell opposition we got around
three Waters we could open ourselves up
to literally hundreds of these things
and even if we have a a fast track
pulmonary system which is in here to do
that uh I think that's that for me that
goes a step too far so just throw that
out for discussion and concur yep thank
you
you're right yeah I would agree
considering that the code of conduct
um is for the CE and the uh elected
members so it doesn't actually include
we we don't expect the public to behave
but yeah you know like it's asked to
work both ways and sure and being
members this applies to them yep
anybody else want to discuss on that
Michael I understand that the suggestion
of the members of public Council lgnz
something that lgnz has been raising is
something that can be discussed in
cradle conducts and it's also from uh
personal experience of the last term for
my team and uh just noticing code of
conduct issues um it's a suggestion if
the council is not comfortable with it
then we can be directed to remove
their ability yeah right
um I think if there was an issue with an
elected member or something like that
the first protocol would be yourself are
you represent the council and if someone
had an issue then yeah I mean you've got
an open door policy so look I've had
those sorts of emails already yeah a
couple occasions have been about staff
members I've just taken them to clear
and said this is the feedback I'm
getting I don't know the feel of the
process just it's just for her eyes only
and so that's a good Waypoint on page 94
you'll notice that um as part of this
process
um Michael and Cliff attempted to
um
to make our response to complaints a
little bit more effective what we've had
in the past for those who haven't been
here is that when a code of conduct is
lodged it gets processed through to an
investigator
so there's two issues about the
investigation the investigator does the
primary investigation to decide whether
there's any material cause to be worried
about if not it comes back if if there
is some material course it goes forward
for a full investigation
the downside of that is that one is cost
involved two there's time involved and
three there's a perception that an
investigator has a fiscal incentive in
some people's eyes they actually gave
the full investigation has to pay as the
primary one
um and so I think it's quite a healthy
process that we've come to say the
initial investigation which is referred
to as the primary investigation will
assessment should be done away from the
full investigation to see whether it's
something can be resolved internally and
then we've got mechanisms for that and
and whether it's okay for me I have some
unease about that initial primary
assessment being done by our legal team
which is Michael's team I think when you
have a staff member potentially
deciding on conflict between councilors
or potentially between a counselor and
the chief executive it puts the staff
member in an invidious position
so one thing I've suggested to both
Michael and declare and the days leading
up to this is that I'd like to see that
go out to Preston Russell law
and that we have some one designated
partner there that deals with these
preliminary investigations one of the
issues that we had
with the previous setup we had was that
it's um it's a bit of a lolly scramble
here you get to do the investigation we
had a pound of four or five people or
alternatively some may not be available
and you end up with one person doing it
um and there didn't seem to be some
consistency away the approach was done
to it depending on who the investigator
was for those who were here last time
you'll know that we have the local
government commission come around and
one of the issues that they raised was
having more localized input into the
preliminary area which is what we're now
looking for and secondly to have
standardized Regional people that would
invest instead of buying something from
Wellington or Auckland because of the
cost factors and also that they would
give some steer to the government on
what the penalty should be because some
of the penalties are described as always
but a wet bus ticket as you know and so
we have some bad examples of that last
term and so this to me steps in the
right direction but having the internal
staff members do it I'm uneasy about it
so I'm over I'm opening that up for
discussion
you're Tom
my um the um I mean it seems the obvious
thing is that the preliminary
investigator must be a different person
than the independent investigator that's
the latest stage should give two
separate people
um I would support what you're proposing
the the even the initial assessment
should be done externally yeah
yeah
anybody else want to contribute to that
yeah so I've got a contrary view uh and
that I think for the initial
investigation which is simply to
determine whether or not there is
something to be investigated as
something that I feel I can have faith
in in our staff and any professionalism
to deal with
they're just making a call as to look
this is this is a substantial matter or
not
and if it's a substantial matter then it
goes outside the building
so just make one comment of that I'm not
trying to downgrade what you just said
one of the things I discussed with
Michael early on today was what I mean
yesterday
um was the fact that as we go further
through this process there's no appeal
right
um within our process against what the
preliminary investigator decides so if
you felt agreed if I have um have I lied
to complaint against clear for open sake
because I thought something she'd done
was not appropriate and then Michael
investigates it and rules in favor of
Claire I've got nowhere to go with that
and I might feel aggrieved or I might
feel well it's one of her senior staff
he's not going to do it now there's no
reflection on Mike and I've told him
that's it's nothing personal to him or
his team but I just a lot of this is
about is about perception of fairness
and when you get into things like
personal grievances very much process
driven so that people feel as though
they get a fair Shake because as we move
on to this you'll see there's some
things fill in the process that need to
be looked at as well Trish
um I support Tom's point of view I think
we've got to eliminate any kind of risk
that we can and I think
um well I understand what Darren's
saying I think it would be
what seems to me would be better to do
it outside straight away
so uh any other debate on it it's got me
Leslie
thank you
every time reference to
Preston Russell May
end up being an expensive option we do
not necessarily need to always access if
it is a complaint that could be dealt
with by an internal team preliminary
assessment so I tend to think it's
probably an either or there will be some
cases where
your view is indeed the correct one and
it is better to have the totally
independent view from the start there
will be other cases where it is quite
appropriate that it's
an internal assessment
somebody else had to hear that there
yeah Ellen I was gonna say if you have a
a situation like customer service
talking about where you actually have
discretion whether you do a donut within
where you're back to square one aren't
you so you've got to have a clear path
you either do or you don't
in my view you know my I suggest talking
yourself
fresh
yeah that um I think you should involve
an outside external thing straight away
because especially yeah well an
unemployment issue but it's close to an
employment issue
um
oh sorry Peter yeah I did have my hand
over that's okay uh yeah I was going to
also suggest that we use the city
solicitor yeah
okay
uh Michael I'll give you a chance to oh
sorry
um I just wondered about the degree of
where we're at so perhaps you could give
us a couple of examples Michael in the
sense of
the low end and then the higher end of
where we might might not act because
pretty sure that we're not too too
concerned about someone borrowing some
biscuits from the uh tea caddy or
whatever
um we'd know who that was yeah we know
who that is yeah we do
um but Michael yeah I just think we need
to be careful here because we're running
off to to a legal firm on something that
could be dealt with quite simply
internally so perhaps a couple of
examples will be good for everybody
could you give us a couple no absolutely
so I'll just quickly preface that but
this was the intention of this was to
try and cut some of that cost down sure
um and that was the intention and the
legal team would be myself and Andrew
Cameron as the two people in the
the organization who hold a practicing
certificate
um
enter there was that intention but yeah
again
discuss between Andrew and myself our
idea would be that if Claire had made
the code of conduct complaint as the
chief executive that would be going to
Preston Russell um simply because that
would put Andrew and I and a position
that people would assume we would back
out to if executive
um
uh whereas complaints around from
councilors uh they can be things that
can be dealt with and as you said there
are things that are
lower level
but to try and Define that sufficiently
to put in standing mode sorry standing
what is the code of conduct so that
everybody knew whether this was in or
out is actually quite
difficult so I think so in terms of code
or conduct complaints
uh something simple like
name calling
would potentially be at a lower level
that we would be able to internally deal
with serious accusations about a
councilor's Integrity or um pecuniary
interest or things like that uh
involving people's family members and
things that would be something that I
would consider on the more serious level
um
but of course it's always a matter of
degree and to the circumstance that the
code of conduct
first came up
from so
it's a it's there's a Continuum and it's
actually quite hard to put things on it
until you've got them in place but there
are just a couple of examples from the
top of my head so perhaps to help me
further are there examples from other
councils that you're aware of from your
knowledge and experience where they're
there's that definitive line is there
some examples that we could use or
they absolutely will be we think we only
need to look as far as Dunedin city
council from the last few terms with a
certain very famous counselor
um that code of conduct obviously
went
all the way to the Supreme Court it was
quite safe to say uh so you've sort of
got that at one end of Behavior Uh
coming back to
pick in that sort of
General name calling within the chamber
and there are code of conducts where
that has been investigated
yeah and so I sort of those are sort of
you're too extreme so they're a case
from Dunedin
obviously involved staff member and was
bought
um where he that counselor was obviously
very aggressive and confrontational to
staff and that was brought home by the
chief executive from memory
um
so again was
at that more serious level with how that
counselor conducted himself
um
two things I'll deal with the easy one
first the uh I do agree that in-house
with counselors is absolutely fine I
think that's a nice clean I have a lot
of respect for both Andrew
Michael
and being very professional and I think
anything involves the CE was immediately
external and that to me that's a
no-brainer
um
you mentioned uh name calling uh it's an
interesting one because it takes me back
to October 2014 where
um I was subject to actually variable
abuse now I don't know whether name
calling you know trips up on that and
nothing ever evolved about the incident
and it was an interesting one so yeah
you know just Just Awaken an old wound
I apologize that's fine
yeah it was outside a meeting
not that I was still in the council
chamber
um
this is the proverbial suspension of
20.6 comes to me where I'm having a
second bite at the Cherry
um I'm comfortable still with staff
handling it more so because there's a uh
the staged approach but because it's not
being dealt with by one person yeah if
we've got two practicing lawyers
Consulting with each other then I think
that should create a sufficient level of
comfort or for Council yeah
yeah Tom
um Chad actually lead counselor supers
proposal
um the the question then as well he
makes a decision and and I would suggest
that
um that would be a decision in the
mirror whether it's home would then turn
there externally
um unless the meat is subject to the
complete in which cases
yeah yeah
because the other option is we can use
the independence year of risk and
assurance
so we've got one there that's neutral to
all of this and Bruce is a very skilled
operator
um so there are options that we have so
um
I guess Michael you're getting a bit of
a
a blurred vision here in a little bit
away but I guess what I'm picking up as
it is that for low level
um
disputes I guess between counselors
Collective members it would go to your
team we're involved the chief executive
it will go to press press and Russell
law
um and both of those allow for a
preliminary investigation that doesn't
um set the pathway down the more formal
way
yeah great yeah so so what we're saying
is except where it's it
are combining it's a CE or complaints
initially will be screened through
Andrew and Michael correct yeah yeah and
then they would be the decision point
where it either is external or is dealt
with internally yep yeah everybody okay
with it excellent nodding around table
you got that Michael thank you hey you
get around winning that's another issue
on to page 112 of board books
um
there's some wording in there Michael it
doesn't quite sit right with me
um
in in 15 to 4 it says after complaint is
referred to the legal team
um the parties to the complaint are
revised and I have some issue with that
um being mindful that complaints go to
the chief executive or to the chair risk
and assurance
I think people that are subject to or a
code of conduct complaint should know
before it gets referred on to the Ambit
problem investigation that there is a
complaint in place
um
so I guess a name change for me would be
before the complaint is referred on that
the parties are advised that there
actually is a complaint because that was
a problem with the previous system it
sort of said that it went to the chief
executive and then they got referred on
for some second reaction but the
litigants as it were didn't know what
was going on they got it sort of a
second hand and if you think about
personal groups and things
um it's important that you have that
information up front
so I'm opening that up for discussion
again right you're looking frowned look
on your face thinking thinking it's good
to think Wally Ponders uh mayor Clark
can I just point out that um it's the
risk and Assurance committee under 15.2
not the Rick and assurance
a consistent one through that particular
pair
I picked it up we were just making sure
that people actually read our code of
conduct
thank you
I apologize for that and we will get it
corrected yeah
so um
on page 114 on 15 to 16 it says we're
investigating the complaint the
independent investigator
so this I guess is where we're into a
more formal process
May consult with a complaint with
respondents and effective parties
undertake a hearing of relevant parties
and refer to any other documents I would
have thought that may as too subjective
I mean uh natural Justice and these
vegan guys on that would require that if
you investigating a complaint between
two parties that both parties should be
involved you don't have a discretion to
not do one of them
so any discussion around that
so I pondered yeah are you upon it just
Michael if you could in terms of
so if an initially a complaint's made
then you would review that and it's not
against the sea then you would review
that and make a decision on whether it
then would be investigated or it's just
passed away no no no initially when you
make a complaint it goes to the chief
executive or the chair of risk and
Assurance who then passes it on for a
primary okay so once I've passed it on
that disorder that's something that
needs to be yep investigative one yeah
and so what I was suggesting is before
it gets passed on to the uh preliminary
investigator be it Michael's team or
Preston Russell law who involved the
chief executive the party should be
advised before that not after it's been
done
okay
so going back to that Michael just on
that 15 to 16. Leslie which is just the
wording May
yeah thank you are you suggesting that
there may be changed to a must yeah or
should or whatever it should be it
should be must you can't you can't do an
investigation which is not a frivolous
investigation the fact that's gone on to
the full investigation I mean there's
some material contents to it
um it leaves it open to discretion that
um you you could in some ways not
discuss it with
if it's mandatory thing to talk to both
parties in any other effective party
because sometimes that happens
and rangie swears at me and we get a
coat of comment but there are other
affected people involved in it
um
I'm very comfortable to make that uh
yeah Leslie my preference would
certainly be that it said must in this
case because Mae does have a yeah
at this point it's gone to an
independent investigator so the must
becomes
um unnecessary comprehensive word
so that's me done and this is other
people
trolled right through the document which
is recently extensive
if we can just go back to your earlier
remark yes um which where are we
all on end
information to the complainant
in the
respondent well if I think about two
elected members having having some sort
of dispute in one of them lodges a
complaint it would primarily go to clear
she's not involved I would expect at
that stage before it went anywhere else
be it away for Michael's team or or to
investigate preliminary that we the the
parties that are at odds should be
advised there has been a complaint
because you know the way this place
works great Wine Works really really
well there's nothing worse than to hear
things second hand
um and if you've if you've worked in in
the area of employment law which I have
and around that it's very important that
when you get into these processes to be
upfront very early on in the process
it creates problems if you don't think
of processes are
things that people hang their heads on
have not been heard properly
so that's what I was suggesting
how long were you in visiting 15.2.3
would take that has given you a concern
what what page on it's one one two
fifteen two three and fifteen two four
that's the ones you were suggesting so
on receipt of a complaint chief
executive or the independent chair of
risk and Assurance will refer that
complaint to the legal team and then 15
through 4 says after the claim complaint
is referred the chief executive or
independent chair will inform the
complainant and the respondent so are
you worried about a time delay at
fifteen two three
so my view of that is that the party
should be advised before the referrals
made for a preliminary investigation
and the process
it's your suggestion that on the receipt
the parties should be advised
yeah sure so a clear receives one for me
against I mean it's Nigel first step is
to advise both parties obviously I
already know but to buy the other party
yes there's been a complaint
um and then it goes on for its
preliminary investigation because one of
the things about this is
when Michael and his team have done
their work some of the outcomes are more
Consulting and you see in the in the
document that talks about um maybe the
mayor or a chair getting involved as
part of a resolution from that that low
level stuff to make sure that we get
past it and so uh one thing that stops
that sometimes if people feel as though
they left out of the process early on
so that's all I'd say is it just change
the word from after the referral to
before the referral
just a matter of timing
it's an easy change to make
and it is appropriate that the person
who has had the code of chronic made
against them as aware of that no it's
very early yeah
okay
any further discussion on the code of
conduct
everybody's all right yes
this is an interesting one on uh Paige
on yeah 120 it's the Crimes Act 1961.
uh Michael
now the first bit uh is about receiving
gifts and stuff but the bit that
interests me
is it is also a crime for any elected
member to use information
acquired in their official capacity for
monetary gain or Advantage now
is that referring to information that's
in a like public excluded
format as opposed to public
because obviously when you read below
the next bit's quite scary these events
are punishable by a term of imprisonment
of seven years yes or more
so can I suggest I need an example that
might be that he might be party to some
some sensitive information around a
tender that we've got or potential
funding for a project and you jump in
and help a business that you own or
somebody you know to put in a lower bid
program and say
um that sort of you've got information
that can benefit others but not benefit
the organization
that's an example yeah yeah it's a band
thank you Clark you're absolutely
correct and the reality is most of that
will be public excluded information if
it's in the public realm then people
will know about it but that you know
it's always tempered by how much
knowledge you have in addition to what
is available in the public Realm but
I suspect this will be but this is the
public excluded information and Mia
Clark's example is a very good one
another one as you no no just so it's
obviously you know using information
acquired in their official capacity yes
uh just you know just trying to get the
clarity around so it covers everything
but
your risk as your public excluded
information right serious
any other discussion on the code of
conduct
I'm going to sleep all right but
somebody like to move and second the uh
three recommendations that we have in
front of us
Leslie thank you again right
any discussion around those
so basically we're receiving the report
we're revoking the previous code of
conduct which is dated 2016 and adopting
the 2002 2022 Co which is uh set out in
appendix a all those in favor
in the opposition
done business
moving on to the next Gene writing which
is the adoption of the government
statement
so quite a long document
anything you'd like to initially
contribute Mike
just to point out mayor Clark that the
governance statement will need to come
back for further adoption once the final
appointments to all the
um
committees such as the district
licensing committee and the other
Council appointments are completed other
than that it is a long document but a
necessary document that we
must have and we do continually update
it as situations change yeah so on page
144 you've already identified from an
earlier document that uh
unless he would like to be on
um
finance and projects committee
yes that brings the numbers up to three
four six seven those will be corrected
as opposed to eight
and given that I have the ability to be
on there as well
I don't have anything else to raise it
in relation to that
any further questions yes Darren sorry
happy to
um put myself forward to cheer the
hearings panel since I'm the only one
with the qualification yes I saw that in
there
um and I I think from memory we had
two or three other people wanting to do
the Commissioners with you you've got
some control of that
I think
the more the more the merrier yeah I
really had discussed that she was
interested Trish has I don't think there
was a third one Peter has yeah
it's rigorous
I'm a rigorous person okay excellent
rainy
um I have an issue on page 147 and that
is with the wastenet appointments now
I'm under the impression that it's going
the way of the dinosaur
um waste net
it's it's
going to be
um it's no longer going to
be a tri-council governance thing it may
remain a tri-council management
agreement
but um
I see no point
and appointing people I'm not sure what
the other two councils are doing but I'm
strongly against the continuance of
that governance group for
oh I don't want to get into it here but
I would object to that continuance
yeah something in one of our further
papers that we've got
um
there's um quite a bit of overlap into
your infrastructure committee here
that's where we want it to go um
so yeah we can address that as we get
down to the appointments which will come
later than us
about whether we want to still
participate that in that framework or
not it certainly would be my view that
it has an adult on a value
that we're better off doing it ourselves
no absolutely thank you
all right any further discussion on the
uh
adoption of the government statement
2022-25
there being none some of you like to
move and second that we accept those
yep thank you both counselors any
opposition to that or any discussion
none there being none
um I'll put all three at the same time
well that's in favor say all right
caring
Now we move on to the issue of monofin
representation roles and responsibility
2022-25
so I'll leave this a little bit
um so you'll have some involvement in it
already
um
so um
I've had discussion with both women
leadership so I've had deanan from our
and Cyril and Joan from waihopai and
explained that we're moving here
decision making away from committees and
into the full Council which is what we
used to have before we got to the last
train
and we all know the reasons why we moved
downwards so then the question becomes
at what stage do the minor funeral reps
have an involvement so clearly at the
stage they remain on the Committees that
they're on before which is the two big
committees and have writing rights there
the issue for us to decide on is whether
they participate but don't vote at the
governance level or whether they um
don't do either they can't vote at the
governance level at the decision-making
body the ACT does not allow for that
but it's where they have a voice there
without a vote so I'll open that up for
discussion shortly
um
I have discussed with all three leaders
that came to see me that I'm
uncomfortable about speaking but not
voting
um on on suitable levels
um one of the issues I discuss with them
is it doesn't sit right in the public
eye we have non-elected members on that
board that's and we've got a lot of
feedback over the election campaign
about that the other issue is it doesn't
sit well for me if Mala Fenway are
allowed to talk but can't vote that
seems to be a bit of a double standard
in my view so there should either be
both or neither
um but the wording of the purpose and
the summary on page whatever on page 163
um
for me is a little bit vague Michael it
just doesn't quite identify where they
can speak but not vote so I'd like to go
around the table and see how people feel
about them
because in the recommendations as we go
forward there are two recommendations
that I would personally be opposed to
which is uh recommendation five and
um N7 as well
before we do that if we could just touch
on what our feelings are all views are
on the role of male or female on the
council itself you're down
thanks mayor Clark uh look I'm I'm happy
to to kick off and I guess I'd like to
um
share with counselors
that the manafinoa representatives are
appointees they're not elected
um members like us but they are
appointed
and it's no different to
if we look at the previous dhbs and
councilor Soper will recall that there
were people on the dhbs who were both
elected and those who were government
appointees
we know because of the act that they
can't have a vote at full Council
there's absolutely no question if that
is at all
but I think because there's a distance
of a week or a fortnight between the
discussions at the Committees and when
items come up again at full Council it
would be useful to have the monofino
with viewpoints reflected at the meeting
and that's why I don't have an issue
with speaking rights at full Council but
understand that there aren't voting
rights
I'm silent on point seven
yeah
all right Leslie
thank you Mia Clark at the risk of being
second of third speakers possibly we're
going to have everybody's view on this
one bringing up this standing order
um I'm I'm also going to speak in favor
of
of the
principles with which we agreed to the
appointment of manafina or
Representatives we're all well aware
that the ACT doesn't allow
um
non-elected members to vote at the
council table Mana funeral reps have set
at the council table in our last term in
spoken
um often with exceptional value on
issues and have been not of course been
able to vote
um I'm in favor that we
leave number five is resolving that we
continue the appointment on full Council
I would even go as far as to say and
speaking rights but is non-voting
members
if you want to be explicit about the
non-voting membership which is in the
act on recommendation seven I am
certainly in favor of confirming the
honor area to remain as it is yeah I'll
come back to see another minute because
there's some further developmental there
which I'll discussed with ewe itself so
urangi
right I would
my preferred option is that the
manufenora wraps are on the two main
committees but not on Council the reason
being is that
we've just gone through an election and
it's a harrowing time for all those who
stood and put a lot of
um
and there's a lot of people who didn't
get on who put a lot of effort into it
now to me that sets the bar of elected
members
of being at the top table
and that the input for the two main
committees amount of federal reps still
have and that input is valued
but
I I see two stages one is advisors and
then the next one is you have elected
final decision makers who said at the
table and to me that is why I see it and
you know if you look at what is a repeat
again what the elected members went
through over the last few months
and they do it every three years I I'm
quite strong about that
there you go Peter
thank you misdemeanor
yeah I believe that we should
have a presence here with monofino reps
but I honestly believe that they should
sit in the peripheral the same as staff
members do
and when we require advice or
clarification as we do with staff
members they can then be invited by the
chair
to sit at the top of the table
and go through whatever issues or
information that we require from them
and then they take their place back
where they come from and they peripheral
thank you for that like members of the
public
because I only have a say if they at
public forum and they've got five
minutes so
yeah that's what I like to say I'd like
to talk about the honorrhea but do you
say that's coming up after come back
down I just want to finish the
discussion around this number five so it
was for a Miss of me to not share some
information uh one of the issues I've
spoke to with the leadership of both
Moon Angus and I think
uh one of the um ropes has asked me I
think Pioneer here someone online is
what happens when we go into public
excluded are the monofino rips and
you've touched on this uh public and do
they have to leave or do they stay my
view that Wellness only my view is that
we should treat the same way as external
advisors we had that we we record in the
meeting that there they stay because
while they may or may not be able to
participate if they're not able to
participate they should still be here to
hear what goes on it's a bit
disempowering to be part of a submission
that comes forward from a committee and
then have to leave the room and not hear
what the decision is
um I think that's not a good process so
just a reflection on that but we need to
go around the table and ask people we
this is one of the toughest for us to
decide on I'm just doing a bit of a
count here so
and get some idea where we're going to
go to and what how we resolve this
so I'll just go around the room Grant
having representation full Council yeah
okay
so that means they participate but they
don't vote Yes yes correct Tom
I think if we were debating this as a
exercise in Civics for the first time
um I I think the points that you made
would be
um
would be powerful I I did however feel
as though since monofino I did attend
Council last time to actually remove
them as a step I think in my view a step
too far so I I would support manafinoa
attending um Phil Council meetings
um was speaking rates but not voting
rates and I and I did take counselor
cats
um suggestion and I'm trying to think
here that would work but maybe as we go
down the table we can flush that in a
little bit
so and just just as a comment of that
and I'm not not wanting to debate or
undermine what you've seen one of the
issues we faced last time was um that
because we had our decision making
um
down at the committee level so that was
uh where we can add people including man
of anywhere that's where I think it got
a little bit complicated and that's the
issue we now face they're still on the
Committees but they're not on
um if we went against this motion
they're not on the decision-making body
so that's for us to decide today where
we want to go on that trash
um I support the concept that they are
at the table
having discussions but obviously not
voting okay
Nigel
uh we are the respect and value the
rules that we don't it's quite simple
yeah
so that's in favor
okay
Ellen
oh well I'm sort of thinking about it
um I
I think I'm pretty happy for them to be
at the committee level but I think when
it comes to four Council the legislation
says that they don't give the vote I
think by the amount to actually speak
freely like as a counselor
could and Julie influence decision
making at that level I'm not too sure
maybe that's the purpose of the
legislation
so I'm probably more inclined for them
to be very happy for them to be here
um
very heavy for them to give advice
but I think they shouldn't partake in
the actual discussions of council at
Council for Council
Barry yeah I'm I'm of the same opinion A
bill on actually
um I'm quite heavy from manaping or to
be
um at the air committee stages and
they're be invited here
to a certain Listen and if they've got
an opinion yeah sure they can bring
their opinion but they're not going to
be able to help they have a vote anyway
so
it's my opinion on it
so for those who haven't been counting
that's uh two four six in the favor
and five against
so it'll be my recommendation that we
leave this recommendation on the table
we've got two uh
two members away today
this is too contentious an issue to be
running through with majority and it's
not me trying to get it over the line
don't get me wrong oh I just think we
need
um some more time to think about and
allow Ria and Alex to both come back in
the picture
so um I'm happy to have some discussion
around that as well unless you want to
actually have a vote today so I'm here
every time we come to a consensus well a
difficult decision we're going to put it
off I'm not saying that I'm asking but
if we want as others have said before if
you want an inclusive Council and you
know you've got people away and it's a
contentious issue you can do an awful
lot of damage if you don't buy their
their voice into the process as well but
I'm happy to put it today um
you know where my stand is on this and
I'm quite happy to put put it Forward I
would like to hear from the rest of the
council sure yeah rangi uh look I I
think this seats
um the next three years and because of
that the sake of a couple of weeks
um I have no problem with that because
it is such an important decision and
when it is five six and you've got uh
two two important voices to hear
um I think it's important that you do
that because there is no there is no
rush that it has done today and it's not
it's not delaying it or it's this is not
setting a precedent for other for other
things this is a bit this is like the
inaugural meeting is the inaugural
meeting and things like this get sorted
out here so I'm I'm in favor of what the
mayor is trying to do
so yeah I'll come back in a minute Peter
um you know in relation to that I mean I
don't have a penny both ways on this
issue I hear what you're saying Nigel
because every meeting we come to a
decision-making meeting we will have
people absent I guess one of the issues
is if you're absent your vote is not
cast
um that's an otherwise a chair or a mere
could delay stuff just to get numbers
back and and you can see that in Dunedin
in the last term over the three Waters
issue so I definitely don't want to see
the present for that so I'm open to
whether we put today or not quite happy
to do that Peter
thank you Mr Mia
uh if we delay the
the decision until we get our other two
councilors back at a meeting yeah we may
well have one
or two of us that's not at that meeting
so we're going to end up in the same
position sure so I believe we should
take the vote today okay Darren
um I'm in favor of postponing it because
I'm tremendously confident both
councilors have very strong opinions on
the issue yep
and that was certainly my take as well
um but there is also the president if we
delay because we don't have the numbers
here and avoid delay today and I'm in
opposition to none of our having a voice
as well as as not being able to vote
um you know I Leave Myself open to
criticism that because I didn't have the
numbers
um I can manipulate things and I
definitely don't want down that track
for sure ranging look there's only one
inaugural meeting a term
uh and this is it and I think you
because of that you have the flexibility
yeah um
the rest the meetings aren't the same
yeah
okay I'm gonna make it oh Leslie
sorry
nice to meet you yeah I did yeah sorry
sorry I just didn't hear you I must have
the same problem as Council yeah oh well
I wasn't going to mention that not old
age is it yeah
I suppose since since you're asking for
the um the feelings on this I would
agree with councilor Scout that it is an
issue of such importance
um that
we probably need to take the vote today
um
it is
possibility every meeting that some
counselors are away on some important
issues
um if we're if we set any sort of
Precedence that votes throughout our
term are delayed in the hopes that
people who are apologies will be present
then we will have every issue being put
off for a meeting or another meeting
okay so let me work in another way then
I'll have a show of hands of those who
wish to put the vote today on issue
number five recommendation number five
and that's in the majority we'll run
with that
who wants to put the vote today tonight
yeah that doesn't want to delay I have
the option of potentially delaying it
but if you want it today let's have a
show of hands and and if we get the
majority that we'll run with it
one two three
four
you get that count
come on see your hand going up and
coming down again one two three
on the issue of of uh recommendation so
what was the result sorry about that
well the result was a majority want the
vote carrying today yeah today yeah on
the issue of number seven I didn't raise
with the Emu leadership around the issue
of the honorary
with elected members that feel that the
manofen or it should not get the same as
a full Council rate we debated this last
year and it created some issues that
other councils do uh sort of split
Arrangement where naitahu pays some of
the rate and Council pays the other rate
and ecan's a good example of that and so
I said then that we would look to
um resolve this issue before the end of
the year I don't want it to go into 2023
which is what the paper says that we
should be brave enough to make the
decision early and so the range of
options that I put to the leadership uh
was that a Full Count rate was one a
lesser rate was another a 50 rate with
naito contributing with another and
another option would be to have a per
meeting rate
could be the sign on
but at that stage I had we hadn't seen
the workload of being involved with full
Council without voting rights so I and I
guess my viewers there that that should
not be dragged out till next year
the money fan reps have a right to know
what's coming if there is to be any
change
because the issue is that um
good news is coming forward for us as
we've actually got a pay increase coming
so one of the issues will be I guess is
that then bumps up the amount of federal
rate as well
quite considerably
so Peter I believe we should discuss
that today and not put it off
and I've got other reasons too but I'll
speak later if you wish
I I guess one of the issues is that we
have a range of four or five different
options that we could use to pay a
mountain or a rip or to create another
area I think it's not just something we
can decide on today it's my own personal
view because part of the resolution may
be to talk to naitahu as well about what
they may or may not contribute and where
we go from this I think it would be
disrespectful for not engaging I did
signal the issues but I said that we'd
come back don't say um I'm a little bit
Bound by that to not go back would be uh
disrespectful to the to the issues I put
forward rangi
um I don't think we can we actually
can't vote on it today because we don't
have the options in front of us and the
options as you said need to be
researched so you can't say the 50 50
thing if that is not even possible
um we don't even have a um another
option below the base rate so we're just
picking stuff out of the year so we
actually can't do it today sure without
without information yeah Tom
I presume that status quo continues
until there's some other solution it
does yes absolutely that was the
intention in Michael's paper there was
it said it would continue until
um until until 2023 but if you think
that through if that was to be one July
2023 given that's when our new fiscal
year starts and we pay for this out of
our operating cost is not something it
comes from central government it would
be a bit difficult to justify paying
somebody at the current rate for six or
seven months and then suddenly say oh we
want it to be drop down yeah we'll throw
this through you again chair what I was
meaning was that if it takes several
months to dissolve the question yeah you
know how do those individuals get paid
in meantime and I was suggesting that
the existing yes would continue that's
what Michael for paper does say that
yeah Leslie
thanks Mr chair just wanted to clarify
and I suppose it's in line with what
Tom's just asked
are you suggesting that we put second
recommendation seven as it currently
stands
but you are saying that there may be an
options paper by the end of the year
correct that would reconsider that
matter yep I don't think we should leave
it it needs to be done quickly agree
option seven would give the confirmation
today that I believe is necessary and if
you're then signaling a future paper may
come yep
we may be discussing at a later stage
but option seven would give the
certainty we need for today sure so
Michael
um what's the time frame that we could
move the potential options to consider
do you think what's a reasonable diagram
possible do it before the end of the
year there's no reason to consider why
not there are lots of examples out there
now some of that would also depend mere
Clark on your ability to communicate uh
with naitahu leadership but I would
expect the last meeting of the year late
December would be an opportune time
yep there
so thank you Mick like with that
clarification then
and an indication that people want to
take a vote today
I'll test the meeting and move the five
of the seven recommendations as they
stand okay
any further discussion on that
so just as a point of clarification that
is continuing the appointment of the
monofino representatives on full Council
as non-voting advisory members
I know the at this time is around
payment
yep it is
so Michael just your advice on on
resolution two
because a resolution to specifically
names reps
and I just wonder whether that's our
call to make or whether that's an ewe
call to make so for items like if we
appoint them now
are we assuming that that we have
communicated us to the other two people
and I'm not being pedantic about that
but just you know we're making a call
underneath it doesn't belong to us no
thank you may cluck for that so the area
rips when they were monofino rips when
they were appointed were appointed for
uh terms of three years from the
manofino point of view so that of course
transcends a council trainium
um so that these people will come both
let's go and everyone cook will continue
as Representatives as long as they are
reappointed by this Council should
wish to change their representative then
there would be an approach to us and a
further a paper would come because the
to appoint people to the Committees you
have to appoint name to people you can't
appoint a representative of the Wahoo
building for example yep
okay thank you for that
so Darren you put the motion these are
you signed the motion and if there's a
discussion on that
oh Peter yes voting for what what's up
on the board there
is that correct
correct correct yeah
so if I didn't vote for that yeah
it doesn't mean to say that I'd be
voting for the alternative
because I put up what I'd said earlier
that I said that we need a presence here
but I I wanted them selling in the
peripheral and asked to speak when we
needed them to speak well
let me talk to that please look
um it's it's a one or all you can't have
a boat Penny both ways if monofino are
going to be on full council with
non-voting rights but speaking rights
you can't put them in the second row of
the organization that treats them like a
staff member what I was suggesting
before was if they weren't allowed to
speak on in the committee before Council
um
and therefore couldn't vote either way
that they could still have a presence in
the room if we went into things like PE
we don't still want them to know the
outcome of what they'd recommended from
the committee because that wouldn't be a
an appropriate to exclude them out there
but if you're going to have them on
Council then they sit at the table like
everybody else and they act the same way
as everybody else they can talk and and
debate but they just can't vote
now I'm not an expert on the local
government act so I'm seeking your
viency and possibly Darren and rangi as
well so I just want to be sure in our
mind that if we appoint
to a discussion point that they can be
on Council and discuss that we're not
breaching them in because some of the
wedding in your paper is to me is a
little bit subjective it talks about
things like giving giving act to certain
types of things
um and so
it talks about giving
support to erie's ability to be involved
in the decision making now that doesn't
go forward to say that they are actually
involved with the decision making it
just means you're giving them some
ability to influence I guess and at what
level do we influence so I just want to
be sure that if we go down the track of
appointing them the full council with
non-voting rights that we're not going
to get tripped up anywhere
so Council was able it's been said many
times
only elected members may vote at full
Council Council can have
advisory members sitting on it who can
speak but they can't vote voting is the
important part and the role of council
and that is for Council to decide who
they wish to listen to when they're
making up Council or sorry who to decide
to listen to when they're making up
their minds uh before voting
so there is the local government act as
otherwise silent on this and
specifically provides for voting rights
to be provided to appointees to
committees but is otherwise silent
sitting on Council as to who can speak
at the table but is very clear as who
can vote yep so
yeah Ella I was just going to say that
there's a wee bit of a issue I'm just
you're talking about them sitting on us
advisory members of the council
is it a different role to partake in a
full debate pet council is there a
difference here was it the terminology
for monofino is appointed members
so sorry if there are other advisors or
are they do they partake in full they
can well Michael's now telling us two
different things as an appointed member
of this Council as opposed on LinkedIn
member they can participate in
discussion around their full Council
table but they can't vote on an issue
so and I heard somebody say before but
does that leave them open to
encouraging us to go one word well
that's the case and if you don't like
that then you have some fortitude and
you just don't agree with what they say
so they are appointed under the
terminology that's in here appointed
member and they and issue for us is
whether we uh with the ACT which is
silent for me on on that allows us in
good spirit to
um engage them at the full Council level
so I'd like to get your view on that
Darren and yours as well ringy
not trying to put you on the spot but
just don't know well the the example
that I'd go back to is when we had uh
Jeff Grant and Lindsey McKenzie here
they said on the table they they
contributed yeah joined in
yeah yeah they were here for a reason uh
but
we got the tables extended because of
them yep and uh yeah
I see no difference it's a personal view
but I I feel I would like to hear what
uh monofino Representatives have to say
ultimately
each counselor makes up their own
decision when they cast a vote hmm
value the relationship and want to hear
the voice yep appreciate that one of the
issues that I spoke with the leadership
about was us not hearing the voice
sometimes so certainly at the committee
level
um monofino's voice gets caught in a
whole lot of other chatter or one of the
better words and our minutes are often
very
um non-specific so they just say there's
been a discussion and I go back and look
at some of the previous meetings and I
can't determine what monofino has
actually said some of these key issues
so that's a challenge for us and it
reinforces what you sit down so yeah I'm
happy to put the vote so I just want to
make sure we've got the nominees and the
moving signal
okay any further discussion before we go
to the boat
okie dokie all those in favor in fact it
might be helpful sorry Darren uh
um I'm gonna vote against the Motions
because of the reason that I believe the
vote should have been suspended the
other two members to be here for this
particular item so
um so that's I don't know if you can
record that but that's right I'm quite
happy to call that I think that's yeah
yeah let's record that against it
because are you abstaining no I'm not a
stone it's okay to be opposed
it's okay so
I just want to shut hands on this one so
we're quite clear that there's not any
division on all those in favor
raise our right hands
yep
and opposed
there's two of us do you want it
recorded yeah yep two recorders against
majority voters a favor that's where
we've landed folks
good prices
okay moving on to um
the risk and Assurance committee
membership
all right
you again Michael yes anything you
really like to alert us to in this one
oh this is a continuation of
uh auditor General's advice that we have
an independent chair of our risk
Assurance committee and an independent
member
um Bruce Robertson has built their role
as the chair and Ross Jackson as the
independent chair and we're recommending
that that is continued but for a shorter
period of time for a 12-month
appointment this time outside of that
there's I don't believe too much else
for me to aim
so just to alert you to a couple of
things in here
um one is that I um did suggest that we
have it for a 12-month period only to
see uh where we we really am going
forward
um and uh it's good that Bruce is okay
with that because I think he wanted a
longer period and also denoting the
financial implications the cost of
having the two independent people which
is not an excessive cost in my view
something worth having um is a wider
reflection on this this committee and we
do have members with the hands up to be
on this committee
um you'll know that last time we had an
awful lot of stuff going past this
committee massive amounts I think one
meeting was five hours long and so one
of the things I'd like us to develop as
we go forward is it um as for the chairs
especially the two main chairs or the
two big committees to have some
um discussion with Bruce about what our
level of risk is on issues that need to
go to the committee and What needs to
just go directly to council and another
week there'll be staff members to say
every piece of work's got a risk
attachment and that's true but not every
piece needs to go to a risk of an
insurance committee we've got way too
much going here big just a better we're
gonna go to so
um that's just I guess a little bit of a
backdrop to where we go to
um is there any discussion around the uh
around the issues that are racing that
that we have we received the report that
we have an independent chair and
um and an independent member which is
Ross
um
no debate oh ring yes I'm just talking
with with the last
um a few Risk insurance meetings there's
been a massive amount of audit stuff now
that audit stuff will go to Grants
committee
the audit you know the the annual report
signing off of that
uh Mr Mayor that has to go to the risk
Insurance committee because it has the
relationship with audit right yeah
okay
but you're right it's it's not a good
process at the moment and that's
something we need to review as well I
think as in relationship as in historic
relationship I just think when
when you look at our relationship with
the audit New Zealand and how slow they
are to deliver how we get boxed in with
everything
um
our finance people must be pulling their
hair out of times wouldn't you think
wouldn't you think the finance committee
would deal with Mr Mayor the finance
committee will deal with the monitoring
of financial performance throughout the
year yeah the annual report matters goes
to risk and assurance
just that this is obviously
pre on previous councils I've been on uh
this is it was completely different
yeah I think for you man that the role
and risk profile has shifted since then
and I think given the
polite kiwi understatement testy
relationship that we've had with audit
over these past two years
um and the skill set that Mr Robertson
has I'm very keen for it to remain as is
okay I'm gonna let the young Michael
speak now I can see him at the quantum
High
can you give me a clerk
um just like to remind Council that the
risk and Assurance is actually just
providing a recommendation to council
about the risks that are within the
annual report that is Council that is
signing off the annual report not risk
and assurance
but you're right about the five as now
you're sitting through that you know
without lunch it's pretty tough yeah and
uh um yeah I I mean that and then the
following risk and Assurance was poor
ass you know and and uh and I just I
cannot believe we either need to space
the workload or something yeah because
and it's just it doesn't make any sense
yep so I I've spoken to you know I've
spoken to uh Bruce about this and at the
last meeting that we had on risk and
Assurance he did say that going forward
that was one of the issues he wanted to
do was to look at some way of
gatekeeping out some of that stuff that
doesn't need to go there
because a lot of it seems to go through
a committee on the risk and Assurance
team back to council like there's three
bites of the cherry and just wondering
about the rationale for that and one of
the things I've suggested to him as I
said before which he hasn't agreed to
yet but we'll have some discussion about
it is whether the chairs of the bigger
committees actually make decisions at
the end of Council meetings about what
needs to go down their path and what
doesn't need to get in about
but on the flip side we do need a very
good lens across our finances and our
projects so hence the the finance and
projects committee
um because I think that's new we haven't
done well in the past
keep on top of our finances because now
we're doing it at the end of the year
when you've already got a blowout and if
you get that at the three-month stage
you get an ability to to be Edge on on
what the costs are going for
unless there's no other
further discussion uh some of you like
to move and second
yep thank you happy the second thank you
Leslie
um all those in favor I carried thank
you
and you again Michael
nearly there Mr Mayor thank you so this
one is the adoption of our delegations
register so on the points just been
discussed as risk and Assurance the
delegation to register from Council sets
out what risk and Assurance as a
committee is able to uh consider
it also sets the finance delegations for
Council staff and they're contained
within the second part of that
just as a point of clarification for all
the um counselors to remind the
returning councilors and for the new
councilors there are a number of
delegations from the chief executive two
staff to enable the efficient running of
council uh this register doesn't isn't
approved by Council it is approved by
the chief executive but once it is
finalized for this term it will be
bought through to council for
information so that you're aware of what
those delegations are but they are
delegations that are made by the chief
executive so these are delegations for
example under the resource management
act
um
as opposed to decisions that Council
makes so just put that as a little
caveat and outside of that happy to
answer any questions noting that the
corrections that have already been bad
to the governance statement will be
carried over to this document
so two issues for me Michael on page 184
under the delegations to the
infrastructure committee it says um road
stopping closing and Street naming so my
personal view is the latter is not
appropriate
Street naming is not something as urgent
it should be done in my view at the full
Council level uh if I'm if I'm open
there has been some contention around
that in the last term
from monofinoid delegates who felt that
we should have more Maori names and
streets that was the first thing up
against the tradition that we've had in
Council where the person that develops
the land puts forward names
so I think there's a careful balance
that we should not delegate the decision
to to a committee it should come to full
Council it's not to say they don't
consider it make a recommendation I'm
fine with that but I guess I'm a little
bit uneasy about
um the decision sitting in a committee
as a pope which won't involve all
members than being on Council which does
involve War members and on the next page
this is 185 and the financial
delegations for the community and
well-being committee which is
the Aaron's committee it says financial
delegations to prove expenditure above
the authority delegated to the chief
executive and to approve expenditure not
approved in the long-term plan or annual
plan and I just wonder what that means
now
apologies Mr Mayor that was meant to
have been removed I my understanding is
that the council the Committees do not
have any Financial delegations at all
sets with Council that's fine so I'll
take to delete that from document
oh and since I'm making another
correction uh the oversight of
symmetries and the crematorium was
intended to be with Community well-being
uh not infrastructure so that would be
swapped as well
addition and the last one for me which
is the area that rangi got into earlier
on is on page 190 onwards
sorry it might be a one eight nine on
joint advisory waste net group I mean
there's an awful lot of information in
here and
um it just seems to me that some of it
seems to be superseded by our desire to
deal with this matter as an internal
matter for wasting it up for
infrastructure
and on page 191 it refers to exercise
the wasting it extension pursuant to
Clause 2-5 I think it means is that an A
and B and I can't actually find the
reference of two five when I go back to
two five it says little or nothing so
that would be sorry Mr me that would be
the waste net agreement okay um that's a
reference of this
when the waste knit was set up these
were the delegations that were pulled
straight across from that document and
as ever if the council wishes to change
the waste net Arrangements uh then a
further paper can be requested to make
those changes uh in due course and that
would of course update things like our
governance statement and our delegations
register at that time should waste net
be for example discontinued I'm also
mindful that often bodies need people
who appointed to them to terminate them
and I'm thinking of the legislative
chamber as the Upper House of our
Parliament that had a similar effect
that needed people appointed to index
term
um so it is something that will need to
be dealt with in a paper can be called
upon from our infrastructure team in due
course
so I'm just gonna you don't need to put
your hand up now ringy I know where
you're coming from I'm just going to
bring you the opportunity to give you
some feedback on that because we've had
some discussions before about about this
about the home wasting it content where
we might want to go
which might help you give you a bit of a
steer on that rangi well I mean we had
the failure of waste net providing a
waste minimization management plan as as
statutory law has them do now
um this is a this is a critical thing
and I would like to remove that and go
back to page 183 and actually have a
recycling included under the uh
infrastructure and delegations
on page 183
as well as Solid Waste landfill
Etc
those delegations come under there and
regardless of what wastenet is or maybe
your
you know at least the delegations the
full delegations come back to
infrastructure
so correct me if I'm wrong but the um
the contract that's away from recycling
which is the pickup the bond pickup
contract yeah is that still managed by
three councils underway isn't it correct
it isn't it so they've got other other
work other than just the recycling in
there yeah issues you talk about
yeah well that ultimately needs to come
back to infrastructure so it's your
recommendation that all those contracts
that are currently sitting in that waste
net parcel for one of the better words
should come back to us and that means it
will go back individually to the other
councils we have a shareholding in there
yeah but unfortunately the current set
up with waste net and we count here
today to solve those no I understand
what sort of thing I just don't want to
put us in a position today that stops us
moving forward because we're because of
these delegations
so I guess the advice you're getting
from the chair is that we we need some
advice going forward about
um how we how we manage the whole
wasting Group which is very like as soon
as possible yeah sorry excuse me chair
sure um I have committed to um councilor
pottinger and his role as infrastructure
chair under the previous Council that we
would bring a paper back to the December
council meeting outlining the path at
the review of wastenet and the potential
path
um to dissolving some of those elements
yeah
certainly be my observation the last
four or five six years now we just
haven't kept up a speed of waste in
general we've just got problems all over
the place and there's no reflection on
staff it's just the way the the industry
and the government's moving around these
issues so it'd be good for us to have a
good hand on there well effectively when
you look at the makeup of wastenet you
had
to cancel this from ICC two from core
two from South and District so here you
had four councilors outside of our own
area telling us how to run our own
system sure and nothing came more clear
when we had the issue back in 2019 with
the recycling contract now
ICC should be able to decide its own
recycling contract sorry
um and that's just an example yep so
the Aaron's come over to the paperwork
there and I appreciate it thank you
Leslie
thanks Mr Mia I was
is going to say what Aaron had said and
remind
Council that there had been that
commitment and just point out that at
the moment on page 183 the waste net
joint committee is under the scope of
activities of infrastructure and that
seems to give the perfect ability for
the moving on once that paper has
arrived so until then there's some sense
in the delegation register saying what
it does and that is um our advisor has
pointed out can be altered as new
decisions are made
is that okay with you ring
yeah yep any other discussion on that
this has been a difficult area
um all right something like the move
emotions and there are three of them
receive the report
an option of the delegations reason to
revoke the previous one version two
and adopt the new register 2022 sit down
appendix a I'll move that way
foreign
second to last one Mr Mayor
so this is a new provision uh following
on from changes to the local government
deck requiring the adoption of a
pecuniary interest we just do it come
the legislation the changes to the local
government that come in and take effect
later this month and will require the
register to be up and running in
February so this is the first stage of
that which is to create the register and
appoint the registrar
that is going to be me and my capacity
and any successes to title that may
occur I'm not I'm not expecting a new
title just
putting that out there
um and so the only question we've got
there is that number four is uh whether
you would seek to have appointed member
so this is manafinoa and also uh
Mr Robertson and Mr Jackson from risk
and Assurance whether they would also be
us to complete those forms in the
interests of open democracy there is
still act doesn't require appointed
members to do it
but it's a consideration for this
Council as to whether they would
request those members to do it to for
openness and transparency so outside of
that that I'm happy to answer any
questions on this one sure my personal
preference and for is to confirm
I think if we look back on some of the
issues we've had around uh people who
are being attached to our Council in the
past there have been some question marks
and that's my reflection on Bruce or
anybody else I just think it would be
healthy to have that I think we would
operate with their eyes opened down I
agree happy to move forward confirm so
you should
um the word asked is not the same as the
word require yeah so us means that
someone can say no yeah and I mean I
actually support the world Dallas I mean
I think we we recommend ask couchless
probably the right word that somebody
completes the form
um if they say they do not wish to then
I think you know that seems to be the
legal rate so I'm agreeing with what I'm
just pointing out that yeah pasta is not
the same as required yeah I use that
word for a reason and you're ready to
fight it yeah
require
no or not
so I'm just flashing that out for a
minute Tom so what happens if we ask an
appointment to fill out the register and
they refuse
it doesn't show up
but that crate that crate to risk for us
doesn't it
yeah
no we are required to are we no so Mr
Mia um just for some clarification there
the members aren't required to okay but
if you don't then you may be prosecuted
by the secretary for local government
um so it's a but the penalty isn't such
it's a fine of up to five thousand
dollars it's not a removed from office
kind of penalty so you're not required
to admit there as a potential
consequence for not
um I'm not sure why their government
chose the wording that way but
that's how their legislation has fallen
okay
all right so Darren and Leslie have both
moved and moved on four to confirm
any further discussion on me
they're being none all those in favor
hi thank you very much
you said it was the last one Michael
second last one second to last one the
last one before public excluded
something slightly more entertaining and
appealing I'm sure
committing your lives until the rest of
the uh to the end of the year uh for our
Council meetings
so that is the proposed uh schedule uh
sitting there that does not include any
extraordinary meetings that may need to
be set in place with the exception of
the uh final meetings on the 20th of
December which may be subject to a
movement uh depending on when audit
report back to us so the 20th is out
optimistic fingers crossed this is when
we expected but you need to be prepared
for just in case
we always make sure that there are
buffers
yeah right
yeah I remember signing the annual
report on the last day of the year
before Christmas terrible
um so any discussion around there
there being none
um a mover and a signal
thank you all those a favor
all right
we're out of the council
no oh Public School yep thank you we are
too and the financing project
s
yeah
so thank you to those that have attended
and uh to Louisa and Logan okay
oh yes thank you Darren for moving
and seconding that we're going to
forgive me for speaking with my mouthful
yeah
we've already approved them to sit on
for Council everyone you just wanted to
make sure yeah
join the table
cheers